So it's my pleasure to welcome my friend
Maura here today and we're so lucky to
have her with us.
She's a writer,
an academic who is currently part
of the Harvard Society of fellows.
She just finished her phd at Yale, so we
should all congratulate her afterwards.
And her work is fascinating.
It's at the intersection of social
theory along with histories of labor,
media and Technology in the 20th
and 21st centuries. Her book,
which we'll be talking about today,
is called Labor of love,
the invention of dating. And Maura
is also a founding editor of logic,
which is a new magazine about technology
or Weigel. Thank you for joining us.
Thank you for having me. Whoo.
Okay, so just to kick it off,
I want to start by digging into the book
you've called the Book Labor of Love,
secretly an economic history.
What's the connection between economic
forces and dating and how has that played
out in the last century? Yeah, well,
there are a lot of connections between
economic forces and dating. I feel like,
um,
to backtrack to when I was first starting
to think about the book part of why,
you know,
contrary to what it might seem,
I wasn't always obsessed with dating or
at least not anymore than I think most
people up. We are. Um, and, but, uh,
one aspect of its history that really
interested me is that this practice that
we call dating that we might take for
granted as sort of like natural and not
think about is something historical is
actually like pretty new in human history.
If you look at most societies,
uh,
it's not been the case that young people
go out and meet one another on their
own.
And it's really only emerges when you
start to have large numbers of women in
the workforce. Dating is connected to the
economy in a number of different ways.
But one of the big ways and
part of why as a feminist,
I was excited to write about it,
is it only emerges as a practice when
you have large numbers of women going
outside the home,
going outside private space and the
public space earning their own money.
And we'll sort of like taking control of
their own romantic and sexual lives in
a way that really was pretty
unprecedented. I mean,
it's quite interesting because of
course this happens differently.
My Book's mostly about America, but
we can watch this happen in Asia, uh,
in a different way or like
an African a different way.
But it's the history of dating.
It's very tied to the history
of women entering paid work. Uh,
and then of course there
are some other ways too.
I think that the ways we think about love
and romance are like totally shaped in
a number of ways by the way. We think
about economics, uh, in terms of being,
you know, on the market,
off the market, hard to get.
These are all economic metaphors.
So I think there's a kind of economic
unconscious that how we think of a lot
about a lot of things about dating.
Absolutely.
So how has today's economy reflected
itself in this age of Tinder?
Um, what's the Gig at the
sexual gig economy like? Um,
I think that, uh, I think that, you
know, like every other aspect, our lives,
our romantic and sexual lives are
becoming more flexible and uh,
this has both positive
and negative aspects.
I feel like one reason I wanted to write
the book was to push back against all
these kinds of doom and gloom
and narratives about dating
apps and online dating.
I feel like around 2012, 2013, when
I was first starting in 2013, 2014,
when it's frustrating to
think about these questions,
there were a series of how it
high profile stories in books.
I don't know if folks had like mom's
send these to them or saw them in another
way, but there was like this big end of
men story. Uh, that was in the Atlantic.
There was a huge New York Times
story called the end of courtship.
There's all this anxiety
about hookup culture and uh,
and I'm always interested in these
conversations about crisis because I think
it's where people actually articulate
what they believe men should be and women
should be. So I'm always very suspicious
of them. But at that time anyway,
I was interested in all these articles
that were basically like, you know,
humans have always met and fallen
in love in this, in this way.
And ever since cavemen days, this is
how men and women were until Tinder.
And like now everything's over.
This is like a historian. And as,
as a young person who is still dating
this seem suspicious to me. Uh,
so I wanted part of why I want it to
do this research was I was like, well,
it can't really be the end of sex and
the end of men and they end up loving the
end of courtship all because of
Tinder. Um, so what's behind that? Uh,
so anyway,
that was wanting to push back against
that narrative of like crisis around
courtship was part of how I
got into this project. Yeah.
That's something that really
fascinated me about the book.
It felt like there were these moments
of crisis every time there was new
technology.
And I actually found it pretty comforting.
So you talked in the book about
how when the automobile came out,
people were like,
this is the end of morality.
And at the different stages people
had this moral hand ringing.
So I would love if you could
talk us through some of
those moments and then also
tell us like, is there even such
thing as traditional courtship,
this idea that people seem
to think is being lost?
Is that even something that
exists? Yeah. So totally.
So this will either be really comforting
or really depressing depending on how
you think about it.
But one of the interesting things
about the history of dating is that,
and I start to talk about it by the way,
people often, I call it in the subtitle,
the invention of dating. And people
are like, well, what does that mean?
Having people always dated, and I
joke that dating was invented in 1896.
This is the first time that we
see it and the print record, uh,
being used that word in the way that we
use it now. Um, but basically, and again,
as I was saying earlier,
it's tied to like women entering the
workplace and young people in general
moving to cities and this new kind of
urban culture that you have emerging in
that period.
But when you go back into the history,
the thing that is either comforting or
depressing depending how you think about
it,
is there has never been any time or place
in which people are like dating great,
killing it. I'm sure I'm doing it
right. All the kids are doing it right.
We're not worried about them at
all. It's constantly, you know,
from the very beginning of dating,
dating,
dating is said to be dying or in crisis.
Um,
and one of my favorite research things
is that I learned that during the first
decade or so that you have
women going out with men, uh,
on what we would now think of as the
most traditional looking kind of date,
like going out to dinner,
going out to a movie, uh,
that the first one who do this are often
were arrested on prostitution charges.
Um, and a lot of the early research I did
was in like vice squad reports because
there was no precedent for women going
out on their own with men at or for money
being transacted in courtship. Like
when you think of a Jane Austin novel,
Mr Darcy isn't buying anything.
He's just like going into her living
room and hanging out with her mom,
Elizabeth, that that's
her name. Um, so anyway,
I think that like back
in the very beginning,
like the very first period where
you have this thing called dating,
you have not just handwringing but
literally like arrests and people being
dragged off to reformatory.
And then throughout the history there's
this constant kind of overtone of
anxiety both from the grownups and from
the people who are participating in
dating. Because one thing that's
distinctive is nobody ever knows.
Unlike courtship systems when it,
where it's controlled by parents or
by rabbis or priests or whomever,
a defining feature of dating
is that nobody knows exactly
how you're supposed to
do it. And that's always been true. Right?
So let's paint a picture for
people who haven't read the book.
What came before dating. Yeah.
Uh, so in the book, you know,
of course everywhere has their own
variables and their own situations,
but the dominant middle class system of
courtship and the 19th century is called
calling. Uh, and again, it's
the Jane Austen scenario, right?
You like sit in your living
room, your mom, your aunt,
your sisters are there gentlemen
callers can come visit you. Uh,
it's almost is since I'm an academic,
I always think of it as a kind of awkward,
like office hours, no magic kind of
situation whenever it goes to that.
Um, no one wants to go to my
office hours. Oh. But yeah,
so calling and calling is,
as a system of courtship is
symbolically important. I mean,
I believe that all of our
social practices and code,
all kinds of beliefs about how we think
the world works and what kinds of roles
different people should perform. But it
locates courtship in the home. Right?
So it's like in the territory of
the family, it's being supervised.
It is supposed to be noneconomic.
No money is exchanged. I mean,
I think that's very interesting as it,
it's also very much understood to
be in control of the women. Uh,
I read there's an advice column
and the Ladies Home Journal,
which is like the most popular magazine
in the world around 1900 and there's an
advice columnist called the
lady from Philadelphia who,
and who answers people's
romantic questions and she
would get these letters from
young men saying, oh, can I go call on
a young woman if she hasn't invited me?
And The lady from Philadelphia,
contrary to our belief that men are
always the initiators is absolutely not.
You know, you can, if a woman
doesn't want to see you,
you can't go show up at her
house in this way. So there's,
it's important sense in which the calling
system makes women like the hosts of
courtship. Uh, and this
dramatically changes when people,
when portrait moves from the Living Room
with mom and dad into the public sphere,
which historically has been seen as
the sphere of men, the year of money,
the three of the market.
So it's the predecessor to bumble
women have to make the first move.
Something like that.
I think about it.
I want to hear if your mom
were on bumble maybe. Great.
So we'll,
we'll talk about that in a little bit in
terms of these ideas that we think are
deep seated into our DNA and actually
are relatively new inventions.
So one thing I read was that
you had initially thought
of things like dating and
relationships as maybe too silly or
trivial to warrant serious study.
How did you change and come
to write this book? Yeah,
well this book as my phd supervisor be
happy to tell you it was a distraction
from my main h d research. It wasn't
what I was supposed to be working on it,
you know, where I was in Grad
school. Uh, I feel like, again,
about this time when there were
all these stories coming out,
which I see in a way as a
reaction to the financial crisis,
and we could have a longer conversation
about this, but why around 2013, 2014,
there was all this anxiety
in the air about like,
men are an acting like men
and women aren't, you know,
kids aren't dating properly. But in that
moment, um, and I was in Grad School,
I was getting trained in all these
ways of looking at theory and history.
But of course on my own time,
I spent all my time with my
friends talking about love
and sex and romance soon,
if not all of it,
but quite a lot of it.
And I feel as if I came to this
point where I realized like,
we're all developing these
huge intellectual tool kits
to look at certain kinds
of questions. Um, but why, you know,
why don't we take this other
kind of questions seriously.
And I think in a very
deep way, um, you know,
dating for better or worse is the system
that our culture has in place for like
reproducing the world,
like forming social bonds for
intern biological reproduction,
for setting up a kinship networks.
Like there's very little that's
more serious than that actually.
And I think that there's actually
something really kind of sexist and
conservative about treating some of
these topics is if they don't warrant
serious intellectual consideration.
I mean I think it's kind of funny
to have this whole cultural system,
especially if you're a straight woman
where you've grown up, you know,
your whole life with magazines and movies
and books and all of these cultural
signals telling you, you know,
here's what you should want.
Here's how you should be
if you want to be loved,
which by the way is like the
most important thing about you.
And then the minute that you're
like, ah, I have a question,
I have a question about that.
It's like it's not serious. Don't,
don't waste serious intellectual
energy looking at this.
So I feel as if I came to the project
kind of extra curricularly in graduate
school. But then once I started thinking
about it and all the ways that, um,
that are romantic beliefs are in
meshed and like deep social beliefs,
historical practices,
that kind of thing,
I really felt like it felt important to
take like a serious intellectual lens to
look at the sources of these messages
and the work they were doing in terms of
teaching us to desire. Well, I'm so glad
you did write the book. Oh, thank you.
I was wondering if you would read this
passage us and then I have a followup
question on it.
Ooh, look at this. All right.
I began to feel a need to write this
book when I sensed that I was trying to
make a life according to rules I did
not understand and that the process had
blinded me to mind desires following
my desires was supposed to be the point
did, I had never reflected long enough
to discover whether the feelings that I
believe should be there actually
where I had no idea who I was.
And as long as I kept impersonating
all the women I thought I should be,
I could not receive
love much less give it,
I had no self to choose to give it from.
Yeah,
she was still. So have you ever feel
moved to laughter? It seems like,
I'm trying to be funny,
just like,
so based on that passage and based on
what you know now, I'd love to ask you,
what advice would you give 16 year old
Maura and more broadly if you could
design a class that every high school
girl had to take before entering adult
relationships, what would you
include in that course? Okay,
these are big questions.
Um, I think, I think that,
and I'd be very curious to hear from
people here. I think what's interesting,
if you're a certain kind of ambitious
[inaudible] sort of like high achieving
straight woman,
especially,
you received this one set of messages
about your career and you're supposed to
be confident in your soul to be
able to act in all these ways.
And then you receive basically
opposite messages about your love life.
And indeed, not only are you
not supposed to show initiative,
you're supposed to do all this extra
work to like cover up the fact that you
have that you have those traits.
Um,
so I feel as if if I,
I mean 16 year old more like who
knows what could have helped.
But if I good think about could have
known anything earlier, I think,
I don't know,
I would have liked to be more aware of
the ways in which these rules that are
given to us and these things that
we're taught about how to be,
if we want to be desirable,
um,
serve all these incentives that are
not necessarily our own. I mean,
it's an excellent way to sell
women things like anxiety.
It's like tell them woman that's something
that she didn't even know was a thing
wrong with her and then sell
her the thing to fix it.
It's like an engine of quite a lot of
the economy in general. But I feel as if,
um,
yeah,
this way in which you get so many
messages that are also always about like
repressing your own feelings. Like, if
you think, and we can talk about this,
but do you think about how many self help
franchises are basically like whatever
you might feel like doing, do the
opposite thing. Like don't do that.
Don't show your feelings,
don't express your desires. Um,
I think being aware of the ways in which
that grew out of history that's deeply
sexist and certain institutions and
practices that are deeply sexist is would
have been helpful and probably would've
made me less anxious and self Hayden and
various moments. Um, but it was the other
thing is syllabus. Yeah. So I think,
I mean it's kind of a combination.
It's like what would 16 year old Maura
have benefited from knowing with what you
know now, but what would women
in general benefit from knowing?
And I think the answer of just be
skeptical of somebody telling you that
something's wrong with you and then
trying to sell you something to fix it is
good advice for all of us.
And I think also,
and it's hard for us to do
and it's especially hard
to do in romance because we
all have so much at stake personally
and want to make things work,
but also to think structurally
and systemically sometimes
can be very helpful.
And I think that this is the opposite
of what we usually want from self help.
Usually what we want is a totally normal,
fair thing to want as we were like what
are the 10 tricks that will like help me
navigate this situation, you know,
whether it's professional or personal.
But I think that what is
exciting and radicalizing,
I'm like liberating about studying history
is you see how many of these issues
and problems are in fact
structural and social. Um,
and you know,
there's quite a lot of work left to
do before women are romantic equals or
equals of any kind, um, in, in
all kinds of social situations.
It's substantively and meaningfully and
those solutions can all be done by like
working on yourself personally.
Is that a real pep talk that you've
given your friends where they're like,
what's wrong with me? And then
you're like, it's not you,
it's market forces and society and 100
years of sexist institutions that have
contributed to where you are today.
More than a hundred.
I feel like,
I think that
I have my, trying to think of specific
friend and specific pep talks.
I mean I think this sense in which like
the answer that we get is so often like
work a little harder on yourself.
Do a little bit more about this.
I think that the idea that it's like
that's not the problem isn't always you is
certainly a thing that I've
stressed to friends. Um,
whether I talk about market forces when
we're putting up there and I hope I
don't. Um, but yeah,
so I want to talk a little bit more
about what you mentioned about self help
books.
So you make this really great point in
your book that if you go to a bookstore
and you walked down the self help I all
on your left hand side you might see are
all the career books that tell you lean
in work harder, don't speak with uptalk.
And it's all about like really
putting effort in toward your career.
And then on the righthand side could be
all of these books about your love life
that say whatever you want to do, do the
opposite and not him. It's you. Yeah.
I think I'll quote you here when you
said, um, if you want to call him, don't,
if you want to sleep with him,
don't,
if you slept with him and you want to
call him afterwards, don't, and it's true,
it's like the rules is
literally 32 chapters each
one of which is like don't do
this thing they want to do.
Right.
So I think it's fascinating
to just explore how on one
hand we're being told to
put so much effort in. And on the
other hand we're told to be passive.
So how do you navigate that tension?
Wow, that's a big question. I mean,
I think that again, to look to history,
like a thing that interests me.
To go back to the beginning when we
were saying how this whole phenomenon of
dating is predicated on women being in
the being like mobile in cities having
certain kinds of agency that we hadn't
had historically that it's been,
that you start to see all this romantic
advice as almost like a reaction or an
attempt to control female sexual
sexuality given that it's no longer being
controlled by mom and dad and the
rabbi or the priest. I think that, um,
sorry.
I think that that perspective was very
interesting to get while researching the
book.
It was funny to look at 19th
century advice like advice
for calling cause people
were also anxious about calling,
but there wasn't this emphasis on deceit.
Like I feel like a
contemporary of self help.
There's so much emphasis and I mean
this by the way for straight people
fascinatingly self up for Queer people,
it was very different.
And I think shows how much of this is
about reinforcing certain binary gender
roles actually. But, um, there's
so much emphasis on, you know,
not showing too much about
how you feel or um, you know,
covering up your desire.
And this really only emerges
with dating and this earlier era,
there's much more emphasis on sort of
sincere self expression and straight
forwardness. And I think that in a
lot of ways from a macro perspective,
this is about controlling female sexuality
and how anxious it makes a culture
broadly for women to have certain kinds
of liberties that they hadn't had.
And also if you tell women men are
from Mars and women are from Venus,
it's a lot easier to sell both of them
above to explain the other jet. Yeah,
exactly. I feel like it's, um, very,
very many self help books and kind of be
summarized as like what dudes are like
by a dude.
And I was like,
what women are really like by a woman
that this sort of mutual mystification of
men and women to each other is a very
good engine for selling both sides things.
So this whole idea about women
needs to be passive in dating.
It's often chalked up to
this evolutionary legacy.
Can you talk a little bit about
that and kind of where some of that
pseudoscience emerges from and how that
impacts us today? Yeah. Well I think,
I don't know if folk scene,
I feel like maybe this trend has
peaked and gone down a little bit,
but I feel like the,
the sort of ebbs psych clickbait the
article that's like did men involved to
like women in high heels? Like yes, click
it. This is sort of like a kind of piece.
There's that new book that came out,
casual sex about how Tinder is affecting
monogamy and I think it reinforces a
lot of these ideas. So it's still, it
is that books, I haven't read it yet,
I just read an article about it.
But it was basically saying that like
men had to become monogamous in order to
get married, which gave them access
to women and an ability to reproduce.
But now with Tinder, men have this
easy access to sex when they want.
So there's this bifurcation between like
the place I go for sex in the place I
go for marriage, which is leading
fewer people to want marriage.
It's really amazing how many respectable
academics and scholars in 2017.
It's like never occurred to them
that women might also enjoy sex,
but it's like there's still this idea
that heterosexuality is like this
depressing truths whereby women give his
little sex as I can get away with for
affection.
Um,
and that men do the opposite
or the contrapositive or
whatever the mirror image
of that is.
Um,
I think that it's very comforting to
believe that certain phenomena are natural
or biological or hardwired in
like the Pleistocene era. Uh,
and we all love, we don't, I
don't, I love carbohydrates,
but many people love Paleo diets
are like this idea of, you know,
that something was natural and
it's how Cape people did it.
So it's how we should do it.
Um,
I think that this is very rarely they
useful framework for like explaining human
behavior. We're social creatures
or historical creatures. Um,
this isn't just some wishy washy
kind of social construction thing.
I mean brain scientists talk about the
plasticity of the brain and how quickly
it can change sellers of gene expression
to talk about how much environmental
factors trigger and shape, like which
genes express themselves or not.
So this idea that the
nature of heterosexuality,
it was like established by cave people
and we're still somehow acting that out
always to me seemed um,
very circular and all sorts of ways.
You know, it's often,
um, Stephen Jay Gould,
who's the evolutionary
biologist at Harvard.
Describe this kind of story
is just so stories, um,
but also like just not that useful and
mode of explanation as I was suggesting
earlier.
I can look back at advice columns from
like 1905 and they say totally different
things to what we say now about who
should take the initiative in a courtship
situation or whose role it is.
So I think that like humans are much
stranger and more flexible then this kind
of narrative suggest and it's really
comforting sometimes I think it's kind of
Ed psych narratives are
comforting to everybody.
It's like if you are a conservative,
you know,
if you're a conservative
and certain gender beliefs,
it's reassuring to think like,
oh, things won't change that much.
This is how people are.
Um,
and if you're frustrated
by the lack of progress,
it's like your boyfriend's not a jerky
evolve not to pick up the dry cleaning,
you know? Um, so I think
that these narratives are
very appealing as clickbait,
but I think that they don't really,
they're not very useful actually in
terms of their explanatory power.
And there've been many
critiques within academia of,
of evolutionary psychology specifically.
It's funny,
this is one of these modes of thought
that's like existed in its popularized for
much beyond a much longer
than it's existed and it's
institutionalized academic
form.
I love how you call it clickbait.
And I think it's interesting to note
that it's neither helpful for explaining
gender roles in dating nor for why there
are fewer female engineers at places
like Google or do there.
Um, is there a question?
Implicit question and implicit
question. Um, yeah, I think that,
I mean this is a very, a very charged
lead to talk about here. Again,
I would just say I think that explanations
that refer to some kind of absolute
natural disposition or like
not usually very useful.
And usually when you go back to the
scientists who were being cited, um,
do not hold up to scrutiny.
I think that it's, you know,
there are gender distributions.
It's not that there is no, um,
there are differences among genders,
but I think that usually it'll be like,
you know,
the brain scientists when you ask them
say 10% of this differences due to gender
and 90% of it is due to other factors.
There are more differences among people
button and this one class then across
the classes.
So I think that again,
it's reassuring to certain
people to believe that, you know,
what is natural is good and that nature
sanctions a certain kind of social order.
But, um, but I think this is usually not
a very useful and certainly not a very
progressive way to think
about our relations as humans.
So I just want to underline your point,
which is that if anyone does point to
these things like women being passive and
men being the aggressor and
relationships as natural,
like even looking back a hundred years,
things were totally different.
So it isn't really based in
history. Yeah, no indeed.
History provides plenty of cadre examples.
I mean that's what's so cool to me and
exciting about studying history is like
it's so much weirder than you think in
our social arrangements are so much more
contingent than you might imagine,
which also means that they can be changed.
Incidentally,
I'm sure everyone here knows this,
but programming is originally a
female profession predominantly.
There's a great new book
about this by my friend,
so I'm going to tout it called the
program didn't quality about sort of the
pushing out. I've been doing a
little research at MIT on this,
but the pushing out of female programmers
and the 1980s basically from their
profession.
So the idea that the current gender
distribution reflects some sort of like
timeless biological reality rather than
a certain set of social arrangements to
me seems pretty, pretty tenuous. When
you look at it as recently as you know,
1972 in the 1980s the gender
distributions with that different,
I'm excited to talk to you
about that later. Yeah.
Take that microphone off and talk
about later in this conversation you've
identified yourself as a feminist,
but I read or I heard in another
interview you did that you didn't always
identify as a feminist and in fact you
felt like you could sort of overachieve
your way out of these
glass ceilings situations.
What's been your journey from feeling
like that was a possibility to where you
are now? Yeah, I think, I love
this question. I feel like,
I mean I'd be very curious.
I want to put anyone on the spot,
like who identifies as a feminist here.
Yeah.
I mean I think most of the room,
most of the room. Yeah. Um, I think,
did anyone else, maybe this is a
question people have to think through,
but experienced this thing of like not
identifying that way and then in their
twenties they're like in a later life
period coming to identify that way. Yeah.
Because I think the only thing that makes
me feel less embarrassed of how long
it took me to identify that way is how
many brilliant women I know who say
something similar. Um, I think that
part of it, I'm sure, you know,
I grew up in the 90s I'm sure part of
it was like the historical mood when I
grew up, but I also think
until you reach a certain age,
there's this way that you imagined as
a young woman of a certain kind that if
you're just good enough, if you're just
good enough, it won't apply to you. Um,
it's amazing looking. I mean, I,
I'm thinking about this because of the
Harvey Weinstein stuff today. I mean,
it's amazing when I think about how many
women I admire have since we've gotten
a bit older,
talked about getting sexually harassed
at work and it was his stomach and
prevalent that is, but I think that
when you're younger, you just, you know,
if I just do this right or if I'm just
smart enough, I'm just good enough,
surely this won't apply to me.
And nobody wants to identify with the
class that systematically disadvantaged,
you know,
nobody.
And this comes back to your question about
what's trivialized and what's treated
as on and sort of pink and
frilly. It's female things. Um,
so I think that,
gosh,
it's hard for me to pinpoint the moment
and I do think something the zeitgeists
change.
Like if we look at that moment,
I always think of Beyonce
at the Vietnamese in front
of the big feminist to sign
that there were many things in the air
and like 2013, 2014, I think, you know,
lean in Sheryl Sandberg's
book, uh, all sorts of,
of other cultural signals suggested
that feminism was like trends.
He for the first time in our lives.
I'm sure that influenced me,
but I think that aided a lot of it
is just growing up and entering more
professional situations
are more adult situations.
When you realize that you
can't overachieve your way
out of out of like anything
or everything,
but it's like these,
these structural things do
indeed apply to you. Um,
and no matter how excellent you may be.
And of course this applies,
it goes that saying across intersectional
identities, it's not just women.
I mean this is true for all kinds of,
of groups that are historically oppressed.
But I think that, yeah, I
think it was the experiences,
my twenties and also dating
really terrible if I'm honest,
but both in work and in love.
Um,
I think that I came to that really
realization or did that identification
belatedly.
Yeah. I mean, this really
resonates with me every,
I mean we're similar ages and everything
you said about like if you grow up on
the power puff girls and spice girls
and girl power and being told that girls
can do anything,
you sort of believe it and you don't want
to identify with people who are having
a harder time and maybe
you haven't experienced it,
but at a certain point being the
teacher's pet or doing everything right,
like it doesn't necessarily serve you
and there's like structural things that
are actually affecting you at
work or affecting you in academia.
And I even feel like in Silicon Valley
a lot of risk taking behavior is really
valued,
which in some ways is at odds with this
teacher pet teacher's pet persona that a
lot of women are forced into.
So it's something I've been observing,
which is for women to be
successful and take risks,
they almost have to shed that teacher's
pet persona that they were praised for
for, you know, the first 18
or 22 years of their lives.
It makes sense. And of course when
this runs into issues with age too,
but it's easier to take risks if you have
no caring responsibilities or children
or other kinds of things that are
disproportionately put on women.
So of course this value that's
placed on risk taking, um,
has certain gendered elements as well.
But it's true. I think, you know,
I was raised to be a very good girl.
It was a very good girl for a long time
and you sort of do everything you're
supposed to and realize that it
nonetheless doesn't get you out of this,
you know,
the situation situation.
You might be an odd that that experience
can be very radicalizing. Yeah.
And I think I realized this became a
plotline on the show insecure recently,
which I'm a big fan. I love it. See what,
what part should date of like how
much I realized I thought in shouldn't
statements. It's like, oh, I should I talk
about, are you a Molly? I guess so. Yeah.
I didn't know if I'd claim
to be a full mile, you know,
I don't know if I get to claim that,
but I definitely,
and I opened the book talking about this,
but I realized that I thought so much
about like what I should watch or what I
should want to do or what I should be
doing while my was I doing the right
things and that it's really hard to
shake that and be like, what kind of,
you can't shoot about a want,
what do you want?
But that were very socialized to think
about what it's like the good thing to do
or the right thing to do.
Right. I mean that feels like a very
familiar narrative. If I do these things,
I will be desirable.
Versus like what do I desire and how.
Oftentimes when I debrief with
people after they go on dates,
they talk all about whether or not
the person's seemed interested,
but they don't get to the point where
did they like that person or not.
And I try to kind of
get them to that point.
But it's interesting that our brains
don't naturally say like, what do I want?
It's what should I want? Or how
can I get them to want me? Yeah.
So something that we're working
through. Absolutely. Yeah.
So we've talked a lot about how dating
is this arena where people play out these
gender roles and we have
these scripts we've inherited,
whether it's through books
or culture or movies.
If people in this room or people watching
online want to flip those scripts,
what are some things that we can
do? Wow. I really do you think
a recurring theme that I came across
in the different areas is that despite
this, um, tendency of the
self help industry to miss,
if I men and women to each other actually
like most humans want more similar
things.
You know,
like most humans want some combination
of like sex and intimacy and respect and
communication.
And there that I think that one of the
most harmful scripts is this idea that
men and women are sort of essentially
at odds and that all gender and sexual
relations or this said compromise, um, of,
of women for whom sex is like work.
And you know,
for men it's like correct creation or
something, but that's a whole other topic.
So I think that like it's really
important to get out of that script.
And I think, um, yeah, I don't know.
I think there's so much like gamification
of they or this idea that it's a game
where you master the,
I mean the rules and the game.
These are the two most successful dating
franchises of the past decade or so.
But I think that sort of trying to get
beyond these sort of games and this idea
that partners are mysterious
to one another and,
and do this like slightly more challenging
emotional work of being in touch with
one's own desires is sort of like the
most fundamentally important thing and
scripts. I mean in some of the research
that I cover on hookup culture,
it's so funny you get these young
men again and again saying like,
well I imagine everyone else just having
so much sex and like I feel sad but I
shouldn't because I'm a man and this is,
you know,
this is what men are supposed to want.
And it's like first of all,
none of your classmates are having as
much sex as you think they are or very few
of them. And second of all you
can't shut about a lot. You know,
if you feel sad about this and you feel
you shouldn't because you're supposed to
be masculine and it's not masculine.
I'm Matt.
That belief again about this absolute
gender difference in different aims is
producing a lot of unhappiness.
It's actually very counter
productive for everyone involved.
Do you feel optimistic about
the generation younger than
us? Yeah, I think I do.
I think I do. I think the kids are all
right. I mean I think that, you know,
we have to,
we always have to think about class
difference in geographic differences and
it's very hard to generalize.
But I think the generation below us has
better gender and sexual politics than I
did at their age anyway.
I think that there's a way in which
the Internet is creating new kinds of
discourse and awareness.
Um, I think that there is,
despite the depressing state of affair,
you know,
this apocalyptic smokey state
of affairs in America generally,
there's a lot to feel hopeful
about with young people.
Well since you are on a college campus
and in fact the college campus that you
and I attended, I would be
curious to see whether, um,
women who are undergrads right now,
whether they've been affected
by sort of what you called,
like the beyond say 2013 feminism or so
basically like either on one hand they
are more feminist than we were when we
were in college or it's just an age thing
and maybe they will reach that point of
identifying as a feminist later. I think,
I suspect some people in this
room might be younger than I am,
so we could ask them,
but I,
I think that feminism is trendier than
it was when we were in college that this
idea, my like I can't think if I
have any hard numbers to prove this,
but when I think of like when I encounter
young women now who are in college
around that age,
they think it's cool to be a feminist
and that's a thing they identify as.
I think that Beyonce and Hillary
and Cheryl and all these,
all these women help produce that moment.
Um, which I think is basically, you know,
Tim, Amanda Negocio, dgs,
that we should all be feminists
moment that that really resonated,
which I think is basically a great thing.
I think that there are limitations to um,
I don't know the sort of the
transformation of feminism
into a lifestyle brand
or that's a side thing that
you can just, you know, make,
make a choice individually to be
this way and that that will fix all,
all the problems that women face.
I think that there are limitations to it,
but basically the kids are
more politically aware,
more politically engaged maybe
than we were at their age.
I certainly around these questions
of gender. That's great. Yeah.
I do find that really comforting and
that this idea that there is more gender
fluidity and flipping the scripts and
that people at least whether or not
feminism is being commodified on some,
in some ways it's at least giving
people the space to say like, Hey,
maybe we shouldn't wear really short
skirt so we can get into that final club
and see the list. Yeah. I think
that that does feel, again,
there's a lot more work to do, but that
feels like a basic improvement. Okay.
It wasn't even a conversation they were
having. My friends and I were having, um,
when we were undergrads,
at least not,
not with the same explicitness and
emphaticness that or the CEO's idea
from like,
you know,
from nine to five you were in class and
you were killing it and answering all
the questions and doing well.
But then like what happened at night
was like a different part of your
personality.
And my hope would be that people are kind
of more unified and being that strong
woman like during the day and
in the evening. Yeah. I think
what's privileged, again,
we were both undergraduate,
Harvard and I mentioned a lot of
people here are also sort of, you know,
a certain kind of type that
we saw a lot in college.
I think what's hard is that we were,
we're very conditioned to want to
succeed and get approval. And that's,
you get that for one set
of things professionally or
academically and you get it
for a different set of things
like socially and sexually.
And so there's no real contradiction
between being the straight a student who
wears a teeny tiny skirt and stands
outside of Finals Club at night.
Like they're both ways of seeking
approval from institutions of authority.
And you know, the men and the real
estate of the finals clubs too.
I mean there's this deeply, um, gender
and system of social power that,
that we were really responding to.
It wasn't just in our heads.
So it's this weird way that it's like
you're overachieving by being what someone
else wants,
whether it's on your CV and about a boss
or a teacher or about looking cute at
night. And I think that it takes a lot
of personal strength and also political
solidarity and these more
collective forms of thinking,
the change to change that.
And I do think it's happening.
I love that perspective.
Yeah.
I think it's hard for an 18 year old or
certainly would have been hard for me to
say,
Oh,
success during the day is doing well in
my classes and success night is standing
up to the patriarchy.
Yeah.
Well hopefully we can make standing
up to the patriarchy. Cool.
I think it's already cool on its way.
Yeah.
So I do want to leave time for
questions from the audience. Um,
before we get to that,
I'm going to ask you one more question.
So this is something I ask all my guests
who joined me for these toxic Google.
There is the google.com homepage
that has the Google logo.
And then underneath it,
sometimes there's this line of text.
So if you could write the line of text
for one day and millions of people would
see it as they do their
billions of searches,
what would you put on that line of text?
And since this is a modern romance talk,
maybe what would that line
be to help people with their
dating and relationships?
Oh my gosh. Oh yeah. No
pressure though. No pressure,
I think because I usually think with
Google over those wonderful drawings.
Oh yeah, we do have drawing when I
like, I'm a terrible drawer. We could,
you could commission a Google doodle
for something that's on your mind. No,
I've been thinking a lot. And
again, I feel like, you know,
we've just scratched the
surface of this history,
but I've been thinking a lot about,
about
the leftists and feminists slogan.
Um,
none of us are free until all of us are
free and that might seem like a stretch
from dating. But I think that
there's a way in which, um,
we can have fun at
Romance. Um, and you know,
we not always supposed to be thinking
about the structural and the political,
but men and women, and again, we've
hardly talked about queer dating,
which is the funnest part of
dating history by the way. But, um,
I think that we can't,
it's all very well to say that we're more
flexible in that we're more permissive
about romantic relationships and
family structures and all these things.
But men and women,
um,
can't really meet full romantic
equals until we address these kinds of
underlying social and structural problems.
So again,
they should have these two is,
there was this double vision between
the personal and the social. Um,
but I think that the idea that none of
us are sex until all of us, they're sexy.
None of us are free until all
of us are free as a sentiment.
I've been thinking about a lot.
So that's my grand claim to stake on
the bottom of the Google homepage.
I love that. Well, maybe somebody out
here today can actually get that on there.
Oh yeah. Okay. So now we'll open it
up to questions from the audience.
And Scott has a handheld mic.
Um,
I'm really interested to hear your
perspective on race within dating, um,
race or ethnicity. Um, I recently
heard a podcast on NPR about, um,
dating apps and how it's completely
skewed when it comes to race and yeah,
wait at throughout history or just what
your perspective on it is now in current
times. Yeah, I mean this is a great,
it's a great question, a huge question.
I think that there is all this data and
one thing that's interesting about the
proliferation of these apps is it does
give us much more sort of measurable
information about People's
preferences and behaviors.
There's certainly a lot
of kind of disappointing
information that's come out of
Okcupid and other apps in terms
of how forms of social prejudice,
uh, that we see elsewhere in
society play out in dating. Uh,
there was so many things to
say. I mean, historically,
one thing that's really interesting is
that dating is a practice really emerges
out of the working class
and the early 20th century.
And so you have these really vibrant
dating and go nightlife cultures in the
Harlem Renaissance for instance.
Or you have, um, a really vibrant,
like queer dating culture.
We didn't even talk about,
this isn't my favorite facts,
how a Tgi Fridays,
which was the first singles bar was
invented because the entrepreneur who
started it was like,
we need a gay bar for straight people
often like what I call been dating alleged
potato skins.
But it just like Grindr and Tinder again.
It's like exactly a Tgi Fridays was a
sexy singles bar in the 1960 [inaudible]
it's all the New York. But
anyway, I think that uh,
we often see these sort of
like experimental spaces
where there are kinds of
interracial dating or there
are opportunities to express
other kinds of desire
and affiliation that open up and then
pretty quickly are sort of like captured
and commodified and made mostly
for straight white people. Um,
and it's this sort of always
this horizon of possibility.
Cause one of the things about dating
that's different from organized courtship
is there are possibilities.
I mean is a very hard thing to pin down.
It moves in lots of ways.
And so you do get these sort of
spaces where there are other kinds of
relationships and then, um, it gets sort
of like whitewashed and locked down.
So that's like one historical observation.
I think we can keep
talking about it later.
There's like so many possible
things my mom likes to say don't,
should on yourself.
So I should,
I wish she could've told 16 year old
Margaret that I should on yourself. Um,
but uh, I maybe have kind of a
Google design question for you.
If you could wave a magic wand and kind
of take away a social norm within dating
that you feel like is detrimental to
the way that kind of society design
stating, um, what would you change?
What would you change about,
cause it's almost like as individuals,
we're,
we're functioning in this bigger picture,
so, so much of it you can't control.
But if you could control something,
what would you change?
This is going to sound really, really
grandiose, but I do think that so much,
I'm dating in America and so many of our
practices are still organized by this,
not just assumption or false belief,
but real belief that because we have,
again,
the dating,
the purpose of dating is not always
getting married and reproducing,
but it is the dominant system
that our culture has for that.
And because our culture still treat,
um,
childhood and social reproduction,
these highly privatized ways,
it's not supported socially
very much at all. Uh,
it actually is a reality that for a woman
who hopes to do those things you have,
like there are real incentives to be
married here that shape sexual behavior in
a way that you don't see in like
Scandinavia in the same way, for instance.
So I'm like,
am I allowed to say paid parental leave,
socialized medicine and child care?
Like I feel like those would be some
really good design changes that I do think
actually relieve, would reverberate and
why stop there. Universal basic income.
Oh yeah. That's a complicated one. We have
to think about that. But, uh, but yeah,
I think that, you know, wage inequality
for sure. It's a funny thing, um,
that I get into the
first part of the book.
But how much early dating was often just
a way for women to get men to buy them
dinner because it didn't make enough
money in the city to like afford dinner.
And I think that there are all these
ways that like wage inequality and other
kinds of social inequality and to continue
to shape like the dating unconscious
and those inequalities are still
real as we know. But yeah, I'd,
I'd settle for socialized medicine,
childcare and paid family leave.
Um,
so I've always kind of heard our subscribe
to this pervasive belief that women
are designed to want to like build a
nest and foster home and sort of settle
down.
And men are designed to spread their seed
as far as they possibly can and in so
many different directions as they can.
I'm curious what your research has
uncovered around that from a biological
perspective and if that is just more of
a social norm that we've adapted to or
if there's something inherent about human
beings that makes that sort of true.
Well, one thing that's really interesting,
I do tend to think that it's like,
I joke about this,
but I think it's real.
It's like if there's any widely held
belief about gender and sexuality,
usually the opposite thing is actual time.
There are these new studies,
there are studies that ask,
you know, men and women,
would you like random anonymous
sex? Sorry, I'll get to
the question, I promise.
But random anonymous sex like right now.
And you know the initial findings,
you're like,
oh,
men would love some random anonymous
sex right now and women are not so sure.
But then if you control and
it's like he won't murder you,
like you might get orgasm that that then
suddenly women are much more interested
in that.
It was like some men are,
and it's similar with cin numbers
of children that people want to,
it's like there are recent do recent work.
There's a woman named marina add shade
who's an economist at University of
British Columbia who could public his
published and would know the exact numbers
on this if she were
here. But men, you know,
historically I think there's
this assumption that women
care more about having
children or want children more or
that motherhood is more defining them
fatherhood.
But indeed when you control
for or when you tell him,
I know you might have to do some of the
work that's related to child raising or
you that actually men want children more
and a greater number of children than
women do. So I feel like there
are all these beliefs, um,
that start to shift under scrutiny and
often the opposite of what the general
assumption is true in
terms of settling down.
I mean I do think there is a certain
biological reality that like female
investment in pregnancy
and parenting is greater.
Like a woman has to make a greater
investment of time and physical effort to
become a parent than a,
than a male does.
And there surely is something
biological about that. At the same time.
So much of this is socially conditioned.
Then I think we've seen in societies that
had more robust forms of communalized
childcare where it wasn't just going to
be a private responsibility to take care
of your kids in your home.
That you see very different outcomes
in terms of how much women feel.
Their whole life needs to be
oriented around planning for that.
And I think part of that is a,
it's a reaction to the fact that in our
country and this time there's like very
few other options for getting that
work at home done. Um, I've just,
this is a much longer
different coverage of,
I've just come back from this trip to
China to this matriarchal society where
children are raised communal and have
no fathers and it's very different.
I mean there really are other
ways to live, but I didn't know,
I imagine there's some biological element,
but it's also quite socially constructed
and also variable if you control for,
um, the equivalent of will I have an
orgasm and will he not murdered, you know,
these kinds of variables
as dating has evolved to dating in the
public sphere as it is today as opposed
to calling in the parlor and where maybe
these experiences were more chaperoned
or there was more commentary invited
from your priest or your rabbi or your
parents. How, um,
how that conversation has evolved in,
in ways it's maybe improve like Logan
you're saying like you try to encourage
your friends who are dating to say like,
yeah,
but what did you think of this person?
Um,
if there are ways that we can as like the
armchair therapist for our friends who
are dating,
um,
be more constructive and be more helpful
in navigating the dialogue that is
associated with dating
and maybe the debrief.
It's a really good question.
I think that this will be
a strange thing to say.
I think another thing that's come up a
lot like back when I was on book tour
doing a lot of radio interviews is that
people feel this pressure to always be
dating.
And the same way that our phones mean
that we feel like we should always be
working and our boss can email
us in the middle of the night.
People feel like they
should always be on Tinder.
It should always be on OK cupid.
Um, again, they should, um,
but should be working at it all the time.
And I feel as if this,
I would very often when doing events back
when I was on book tour get a question
where someone would say basically like,
I don't feel like dating right now. Like,
is that okay? Like that's what
the question would boil down to.
And I feel like I also so often just
want to tell friends that it's like we've
completed romantic success
and professional success
and a lot of ways people
often speak about like feeling that
they need to hit certain milestones
romantically as well as
professionally by certain ages.
And I think that to the extent that
it's like you also don't do that and you
know, a lot of, um, well that also goes
back to the biological clock. Yeah. Idea.
Talking about earlier,
this idea that women,
straight women in particular feel all
this pressure to like plan their life out
at every stage.
Um,
I think that so often people seem to
just want permission to like desire
otherwise or to not be dating
or working at at a certain time.
And I also found like,
I think that can be a useful kind of
advice and maybe it sounds very Kumbaya,
but I think that women in particular are
encouraged to be so hard on themselves
and so self critical and
to feel so anxious and we,
that's actually very counterproductive
to establishing intimacy. Um,
but I feel like sometimes I just
want to tell friends like, you don't,
you don't have, um, if what you're,
you're hearing from yourself that you
want is that you don't want to be doing
this right now. That is also okay.
However addictive it might be.
Just swipe all the time. What's the
term? And a normativity had oh, a motto.
Normatively. Lots of
normativity. Yeah. Yeah.
So our friend Mandy is very
into this idea that, um,
we're kind of raised to think that like
the goal in life is to like find one
partner and like everything is like
leading up to this moment of romance and
actually like perhaps lots of
people are happy single on.
That's not necessarily
the goal and everything.
So what does it mean for society to take
a step back and say like perhaps it's
okay for a woman to be seeking something
other than like ultimate coupled them
in partnership. Yeah. And I
think that it's like, again,
it's a hard thing to see in
our own individual lives,
but the purpose of marriage and the
purpose of courtship like has changed
greatly over time.
You know,
when you think to like an
agrarian preindustrial society,
you'd have a range marriage because
extended families are like the unit of
production and you need to be married
to like the dude from next door so that
his brothers and your brothers
can like work the farm.
It's like what marriage becomes
what it becomes about. Love.
Basically around the time of the
industrial revolution is something very
different than that. And maybe we're
entering another new phase, you know,
that the purpose of these relationships
in their functional role in our lives do
change. We're all gonna live to
be so much older than people. Uh,
then people did. I mean, hopefully.
Um, then, uh, they did and you know,
the early 19th century we have very
different working circumstances.
We have very different lives.
And so this idea that um,
a certain kind of like straight,
usually white,
monogamous romantic love is like this one
measure of societal success is really,
is really outdated. I think. Like
there are many ways to live, so yeah,
absolutely.
Any other questions?
You alluded to this a few times,
the differences between, you know,
queer dating historically
and view straight dating and
can you elaborate more on
that? Just some of the
history, the differences.
I'm really curious.
Yeah, totally. I think that it's funny,
it was a thing I struggled with writing
this book because this is a book about
sort of dating as a cultural institution
and for most of the century or so that
people have dated queer dating has not
been like legible adds dating to most of
society at the same time and
perhaps not incidentally.
It's also been like the funnest and most
experimental and best and best place
for you to these terrible a gendered
norms that we see across so much other
dating.
So I think that in my book they should
have two chapters that deal primarily
with LGBTQ dating.
And I think that it often,
the first one sort of deals a lot with
the roaring twenties and the 30s in sort
of speakeasy scenes and these spaces that
are at once like theoretically out of
the public eye,
but then also become sort of like an
avant garde or lead or what's fashionable
for dating.
Um,
you see it again as I was suggesting
in the 60s with this hilarious guy,
Alan Stallman.
He starts Tgi Fridays.
And it's like if we could
scale this restrict people,
we'd make a bazillion
dollars a as indeed he did.
But I think that often you seem cultures
of experimentation not burdened by
these norms about,
you know what I keep joking about
this idea that men and women are like
inevitably at odds and then sex
is this depressing compromise, um,
that allow for a lot more possibility.
I think because there aren't,
or for most of the history of dating
haven't been such overbearing social
scripts about like how men are
and how women are, you know,
Lgbtq folks and have to deal with those
in the same way that often you've seen
much more um,
self awareness or sort of thoughtfulness
about defining desires and expectations
cause there aren't these assumptions
about what they should be. Uh,
I think one part of the book deals a lot
with the AIDS crisis and the safe sex
movement too.
And the ways in which like really
heroic activists around HIV and AIDS,
um,
started building materials to help
couples talk about sexual practices more
specifically and more openly and how that
became really important for people of
all genders and orientations.
But I think that,
so I think that like queer
dating and my book and, and in,
in history,
um,
is often a space of greater
experimentation and self awareness. Uh,
and then often sort of like sets the
trends in the same way you get Tgi Fridays
imitating gay bars. You get
Tinder imitating grinder. Uh,
so it gets sort of co opted and made
and made it less fun for straight people
maybe. But those are
just, those are a couple
of themes that come to mind.
And I also post a lot of things on
Facebook about dating and relationships.
So you can find me at
facebook.com/logan Ury.
Just wanted to say thank you
so much for having so much fun.
Yeah.